dans la capitale le président biden est
maintenant bien installé de nombreux
électeurs
le contraste avec son prédécesseur ne
pourrait être plus prononcé
pas de coup d'éclat dit il deux drames
et plus de discussions autour des enjeux
se réjouit cette électrice dès son
arrivée à la maison blanche
joe biden n'a pas perdu teint
réintégration de l'accord de paris arrêt
de la construction du mur à la frontière
il a rapidement annulé des politiques
phares de donald trump
mais le nouveau président s'est surtout
concentré sur un enjeu clé la lutte
contre la pandémie
les vaccins développés sous
l'administration précédente ont été
administrés à une vitesse accélérée un
énorme plan de relance économique de
2000 milliards de dollars a rapidement
été adopté et donc là ils veulent passer
faire il doit faire des réformes assez
vite pour pouvoir justement avoir un
bilan dès 2022
à moins de deux ans des élections
mi-mandat sept experts constatent que
les démocrates agissent rapidement
certaines réformes exigées par les
membres les plus progressistes du parti
comme l'effacement des dettes étudiantes
ne se sont toujours pas concrétisée mais
avec plusieurs chantiers sociaux en
cours et un plan d'infrastructures qui
met l'accent sur la lutte contre les
changements climatiques ma vie voire 46e
président a de quoi satisfaire au sein
de sa formation politique
we say die swiss re a fait vraiment une
campagne qui était très prudente qui
n'était pas progressiste du tout
où est donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
est tout à fait surprenant et et en même
temps quand on connaît le parcours de
joe biden
c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours en fait
négociés entre la gauche et la droite du
parti qui a toujours fait des compromis
mais depuis 100 jours peu de compromis
avec l'autre partie joe biden qui avait
promis plus d'unité n'hésite pas à avoir
recours au décret présidentiel et au
faible majorité démocrate au congrès
pour légiférer
ce sont des républicains déplore une
approche partisane
il note toutefois que le président
gbagbo ne bénéficie pour l'instant d'un
bon appui populaire pour sa gestion de
la pandémie de jeunes croates chez eux
mais une fois la crise terminée d'autres
enjeux pour s imposer une création les
migrations avec l'arrivée de milliers de
mineurs non accompagnés à la frontière
mais aussi le contrôle des armes à feu
et les inégalités raciales
autant de dossiers qui pourraient mettre
à l'épreuve une maison blanche qui s'est
pour l'instant montré très disciplinés
aussi différents soit il de donald trump
joe biden a au moins un point en commun
avec son prédécesseur celui d'être à la
tête d'un pays qui demeure très
polarisée des états unis que cet
électeur texan décrit comme étant deux
mondes différents
si raphaël bouvy oakley radio-canada
washington